let's go to jason from huntsville
alabama jason you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
hey uh how's it going david going well
all right um
i know we have a queue of caller so i'll
try to keep it short like one or two
questions
um
one of the things i was rattling um kind
of thinking about was
how
um
congress just usually tends to have this
kind of goes back to
neil degrasse tyson how he talked about
when he was a kid he would look up to
like leaders and powerful
um i guess inspiring leaders and when he
looks at congress all he sees is uh
businessman businessman politician uh
law businessman businessman like where
this where are the scientists where the
engineers and i thought
uh wouldn't it
be better i'm sorry about the noise
if
there were more
uh a greater diversity of professions
especially if there were more scientists
and engineers in office
or also architects doctors
um
just civil engineer just
a great diversity of
multiple professions
and perspectives in congress
yes i've spoken about this many times
before absolutely we should be having
people representing us from a much wider
range of industries and uh professions
for sure no doubt about it's hard to
argue against that
and
yeah that's because i remember uh bill
nye you know this science guy would uh
argue i used to believe
it would be a lot better if
only like if there were a lot more
scientists and engineers yeah
were in office but he would come along
and say
uh if there were only scientists and
engineers in office
that wouldn't improve anything because
that's just still one perspective for
sure um
another quick question um i thought a
lot about uh of course donald trump he's
still relevant people are still talking
about him
um it would if it would be more
appropriate that
um if he ever gets held accountable
instead of being
um
jailed or uh imprisoned which is
unlikely wouldn't it be more appropriate
if he
was submitted for psychological
evaluation and admitted into a mental
institution sure i mean here's a you
know it's fine yes it would make sense
to figure out once and for all what is
going on with his with his mental state
but um you know it's very difficult uh
particularly for for people in his
position to forcibly submit to that so i
don't know that it's worth spending too
too much time thinking and talking about
it because it's it's not going to happen
you know
that's unfortunate i mean
wouldn't there be a chance that it could
be court ordered
yes there's obviously a chance but i
can't imagine any path towards that
being what happens
yeah yeah well
it's
it's a thought i had all right um i'll
how do i answer i'll hand over my call
to the next uh all right thank you so
much for the call i very much appreciate
it and a lot of different things on
people's minds today which is uh which
is great let's go next to vitali from
israel vitali you were on the air
hello i wasn't expecting to be uh
selected wow well here we are thanks
anyways yeah
i have a more geopolitical question but
also it pertains to perhaps united
states
now with the
detentions in ukraine
we are
possibly are going to into a
confrontation between nato united states
ukraine and
russia
in your mind
what do you think like the consensus in
the united states would be
if
like a public opinion if it would be
escalating to a war
you're saying like a boots on the ground
type war
any kind of armed conflict yeah um
vitali if you can please turn off
notifications and discord because we can
hear every time that it blinks and it's
very very distracting to to the audience
my belief is
that by a small margin
the you the american people would be in
favor
of the us and nato coming to the defense
of ukraine against hostilities from
russia by a small
margin that's my prediction about what
would happen
okay
thank you
all right vitali from israel there we go
yeah always remember
to turn off
discord notifications very very
important